you know what broth open the quran in
the quran in a random place let's see
what god's got to say but before you do
do a little prayer to god here in your
heart
give me a sign yeah and open the quran
wherever you like
[Music]
there's a new brand on the scene called
alif they make 100 halal raw cat food
there are countless health benefits to
this new raw diet check them out on
instagram at alif.uk they do monthly
subscription boxes and you can get 10
discount on their two week trial box
with my code ali10 check them out now
and let your cat enjoy some nice food
all right so i was okay obviously you
guys know i'm here every saturday i try
to be okay i try to stop to speak to
people but nobody want to talk to me but
then alejandro came by and he said you
know you look like a very jolly guy you
know you didn't seem like that you know
you remind me my mom's like that she's
very jolly here yeah she's got like a
really nice smile me it's a bit dead
yeah
how are you doing how's life i'm good
i'm good that's good man it's nice
meeting you
i get the positive energy you get me so
i'm charging myself right now oh good
okay how old are you uh 25. tell me
about yourself what do you do so i work
at it developer
yeah pretty ten years going to be tennis
i like badminton
i'm not bad at badminton yeah yeah it's
still good sport i like it injury-prone
but yeah so i play tennis regularly and
uh yeah boxer xbox and that's right
very hard yeah i hated every session but
i still go back that's good
okay that's good so i always use going
past with wife to be and you said
basically that i asked you what religion
do you adhere to and you said you're
thinking of reverting yeah okay
tell me what's led to that point so
for me i've always kept religion in a
back burner
my whole life kind of yeah you know as
you're young you go to church you do the
normal things parents want you to do
stuff i did it all and then came to the
country i moved from portugal and i was
like
i don't know what religion really is do
i feel anything do i understand it and i
kind of just put it back burner the
whole time and
for the last three years or so i kind of
thought about oh i actually need to take
my time and go into it fully
and not just logically that's what i
used to be into more spiritually think
outside of the norm outside of science
and the rest so um and then when i met
my girlfriend
and several people actually my friends
and stuff and i always
i would call it admiration for
commitment to a religion so anyone who
did and to me i always thought
people within islam had
something that i wanted to have um
what's that and that's the thing i'm
trying to pin and i still don't
completely understand it but there was i
felt that it's
before i came to islam i've been a
muslim for about nine years going into
ten so i had that feeling i know what
you're saying you know when you look
around like to me it was specifically
how the woman used to wear the hijab and
the buyer i really it caught my
attention uh because i live a lifestyle
of partying and girls and all this kind
of stuff
when it comes to a certain point where
you're just like you know girls that are
dressed half naked et cetera you just
desensitized to it now i'm trying to say
so to me i found it really beautiful i
found it really like modest et cetera so
there was something about them that
really attracted me i don't know if it
was a way of life i don't know if it was
some something that they live by like i
think it's malcolm x and said if you
don't stand up for nothing you'll fall
for anything so it's as if i felt like a
lot of religions were falling down the
root of be going with the norms but
islam was only religion which was like
now these are principles we're not
letting go of that that was to me but
obviously it changed
i do definitely agree with that i think
there was sort of principles that people
led by or they they were living with and
it shows it actually shows you can it's
as if there was a that's all around it
and i had people close by at work and i
could just i was drawn every single time
and that's where i thought
let me actually look into it and i've
been looking to it further tried to read
a bit and try to understand where it's
coming from i say a story but it's more
of a okay i don't know what to call it
yet that's that's that's beautiful man
so have you had a connection with god
before like like have you always had
that connection with god or has it you
know he was in the back burner was
religion in the back burner or was god
so to me i put anything to do with the
faith in the back burner so that went
with religion and everything so as soon
as i allowed myself i literally had to
allow myself to feel
um and that's where you kind of start to
feel more things and just things are
connecting and it's making sense so
that's how you see me happy because i
actually i can feel it's weird
may allah always keep you happy
um so god was always in the picture yeah
yeah i was like that as well so god was
always in the picture but religion
wasn't for me
okay
what's you said you're on the verge of
accepting islam what's stopping you
i think it's myself um i think it's it's
taking accountability for the things i
do and
um respecting i think others to not my
standard but to a full standard
and i think that's probably where i'm
suffering okay now if you came and said
to me ali i'm still not sure if the
prophet muhammad is a final messenger
i'm not sure if i believe in allah i
don't know if quran is the final word of
god i will say to you know what let me
give you some material look into it but
you're telling me that you believe in
allah
god yes
[Music]
do you believe the prophet muhammad the
final messenger
yes do you believe the quran is from god
yes
okay you are
technically a muslim it's like what's
your favorite food
lasagna
i had it yesterday my wife does the best
if you get if you get married i'm
inviting you okay trust me you're gonna
love it yeah okay
now when i asked you that question you
said lasagna what you did you proclaimed
what you already believe inside so i
said you what food you like you knew
inside lasagna and you said to me i like
lasagna the shahada is a bit like that
not compared to lasagna
it's a big big it's a big claim but most
of the times what happens and what
happened to me is i was talking about
islam about two three years
for about good year i knew islam was the
truth but because i said bad habits i
used to think let me fix them then i'll
accept islam but it actually works the
other way around you have to accept the
sound for it to fix it it doesn't work
the other way around you i'm trying to
say so some people come and say
i'm a bad person i i i commit sins once
i fix them then i'll start reading the
quran once i fix that i'll start praying
salah salaam is a five and i say no no
you got it wrong you have to pray and
you have to read the quran and that is
what will stop you sinning not the other
way around
do you know what i'm trying to say
because that's what is god's word that
god's word is going to penetrate the
heart when you pray in front to god that
is what's going to cause you to leave
this sin don't twist it because she says
and claims you and says you know what
nah nah you're still a bad guy he comes
and tricks you i'm trying to say
obviously i don't want to keep it too
long i know why
oh she's balanced she's that should i
forget this
yeah
so what i would say is bro
i'm not the type to i want to say force
but encourage
force people to take their shahadah if
they're not sure but you're telling me
you already believe in allah you believe
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
you believe the quran bro i'm telling
you whatever stopping you is satan i'm
telling you because there is nothing if
you came and said to me
if you came and said to me
i'm not sure if the prophet is a prophet
i would say you know what let's talk
about that i can try to maybe convince
you but you already believe those things
bro don't let it stop you because you
don't know if you're gonna
god forbid die today or tomorrow what
i'm trying to say
so i would say bro shahada is a big
thing but don't think it's something
where it's like oh if i take it now no
no bro it's just the first step you know
what shahadah is it's a key to the door
you open the door
your journey begins
all it is is a journey beginning you're
going to fall short you think i don't
sin come on sin even though i have four
short fools i have short forth but what
islam god almighty is telling you in the
quran is
just know that you have a law that's
forgiven repent
that's it you know what brother open the
quran in the quran in a random place
let's see what god's got to say but
before you do do a little prayer to god
here in your heart
give me a sign yeah and open the quran
wherever you like
[Music]
and pick a random verse if you want
whichever words
[Music]
which one
69 okay
this is surah
ok
ok say o muhammad perceive travel
through the land and observe how was the
end of the criminals and give and give
no over them over them or be in distress
from what they have uh
conspire and they say when is the
fulfillment the promise
if you should be truthful say perhaps it
is closed it is close behind you very
near some of that
some of that for you which is uh which
which are impatient and indeed your lord
is the possessor of the bounty for the
people but most of them are
are not grateful and indeed your lord
knows what uh what breast conceal and
what they declare okay that's a deep
verse because what god almighty's saying
he knows what's inside you and what you
declare okay because what we're talking
about here what's inside you which is
islam and what you declare and at the
beginning here is talking about people
maybe context um
is talking about nations before this
because when allah talks about in the
quran he talks about nations that he
destroyed before yeah and these are
nations that god doesn't destroy god is
not people make gods as if god is this
monster that is looking to destroy
people god wants mercy in paradise
that's what he wants but there's nations
who have sent messengers and messages so
god is saying reflect upon the nations
before and these nations you know what
they used to say to the prophets if
you're truthful let god send this
destruction lesson god sent his
destruction and god doesn't work on
their like oh if you say i'll do it now
god gives them time sends their
messengers until they keep being
arrogant then god sends the punishment
but what is very interesting here is
what is god is saying is that anything
can happen any second kind of stuff i'm
trying to say for these nations
but what's interesting here is god
almighty's saying he knows what
internally you have and what you declare
yeah so it's just as if god is saying
look at the previous nations and learn
lessons out of it but that verse which
is very interesting that says god
almighty knows what you conceal and what
you reveal yeah look god knows inside
that you have embraced i'm trying to say
and for you to from there then we come
to this verse i think bro like for me
personally i'll say don't let it stop
you you know why
because it's just a journey man once you
take a shahadah it's just a journey and
it might be a reason bro that you
stopped today
so i'm going to leave it at you but if
you want to take a shahada bro there is
nothing stopping you and you've got
nothing to lose tell me one good reason
that you can take a shahadah one good
reason there's no reason
there's no reason to not take it okay if
you want bro we can do it together
it's totally up to you
i i i'm not the type to pressure but
genuinely i'm looking for a reason
i can't find one bro
i don't think there's there's a reason
not to that's all yeah
do you want to take it with that should
we do it together it's up to you
[Music]
don't worry
i was just talking to him yeah so i'm
just trying to convince him but i'm not
someone that pushes people to the
shahadah yeah because what i usually do
is i try to assess so i spoke to him i
said do you believe in allah he says yes
i do i said okay do you believe in the
prophet muhammad he said yes i do do you
believe the quran is the final word yes
i do internally he's a muslim he opened
the verse and i told him make a prayer
and open the quran in a random place he
opened the verse where he talks about
god how he destroyed the nations but
then there's a verse where allah says
indeed god knows what you conceal and
what you declare yeah so all i'm just
saying is sister
there's nothing stopping him
do you know anything that'll stop him
taking shahadah there is nothing so i'm
saying he can maybe ask the wife of his
permission yeah but
maybe take a shahadah like with us
because it's just a journey i took my
shahada nine and a half years ago yeah
and i know how it feels where you have
this moment where you're like i'm still
sinning or maybe i'm not perfect allah
doesn't want you to be perfect what god
wants you is to acknowledge you have a
lord
and repent to him and it's just a
journey bro do you think i'm perfect
none of us are perfect god doesn't want
us to be perfect so
there's nothing stopping from taking the
shahadah what do you say
i think it's up to him when he feels
ready um but yeah you didn't already
you talk to me forget ask forget it i
think i i do def i think
no one i guess no one's perfect um i
definitely it's something that i
i see no reason not to do i just keep
it's kind of stalling okay myself okay
your brother in humanity and i want to
be a brother in faith as well yeah i
have to give that little push you know
why because you you believe internally i
told him i said what's your favorite
food he was lasagna i said tell me you
love lazanne he said i love lasagna i
said the child is a bit like that you
internally believe it and like it it's
just declaring it so it's up to you you
can repeat after me
i think it's it's i think you've
actually i feel like you've
you're showing me a good direction to go
to and that is something that i
even right now i'm thinking yeah like
there's no reason not to okay repeat
after me
okay just read after me yeah don't worry
could this be off camera yeah sure if
you want it can be off camera
this is what makes our day here at
salaam guys you know it's very amazing
that you know i've been trying to hear
trying to stop people trying to stop
people like talk nobody wanted to talk
to me you know either would you like a
free quran
okay no problem so it's very interesting
you know they they you know he's he was
not a muslim he's is his wife to be is a
muslim but he came here and i genuinely
asked him what is stopping you and there
was nothing stopping him and because of
that i did give him that little push
because we know shaytan comes here and
there he accepted his time in china
they're going to get married soon and
with our new salah project salah plus
where we teach new reverse and born
muslims how to reconnect back to their
lord
via salaam shallal we invited him to
that inshallah may allah bless every
single one of you guys are watching and
supporting salam and yeah may allah keep
him firm and shall they have righteous
children that will be
foreign
you